what do a violinist who plays her
instrument like a cello
the godfather of portland's soul
and a blind blues virtuoso have in
common
they're all on my plus one tour of the
unexpected in music
oh and who am i
i'm chris funk i play a bit of music you
may have heard of my band
i'm looking at surprising and
extraordinary people in music
[Music]
[Music]
my first stop takes me to duluth
minnesota
there i will meet up with galen lee an
artist who creates music like nobody
else
i've shared the stage with some
incredible people in my life
but the musician i'm meeting today is
truly extraordinary
my name is galen lee and i am a
violinist and a songwriter from duluth
minnesota
i had heard a lot about galen and was
excited to meet her
little did i know that she was also a
fan of the decemberists it turns out she
had heard his play in 2004.
hand spray painted
no way that's hilarious i don't even
have one of these i'm keeping it thank
you
it's coming home oh
my god
[Music]
was born with brittle bone disease which
has left her in a wheelchair
but you'll really forget that after a
few minutes
i started playing the violin when i was
10 years old i loved the way the strings
sounded so the next year the teacher
took it upon herself to help me figure
out how to play up and down like a
little cello
so it just means i had to practice the
same stuff a little bit harder probably
and maybe that was a good thing in
disguise
galen had been a part of the duluth
music scene for years when another
musician gave her a device called a
looping pedal
it allows her to record herself and play
the music back while she's performing
and now i can play a song
[Music]
looping was a mind blower i mean it was
so much a game changer
because it was just such a cool
experience to
to go from one note
to like 10 notes and have it be
orchestrated
it opened up a lot of doors
instrumentally and vocally and
everything just kind of changed when i
got into looping
and then i might want to fade out
so you're engaging all that with your
with your knee yep awesome
i'm always fascinated by the imagination
musicians will use to create new and
fresh sounds but the ingenuity that
galen has shown in her journey to
produce beautiful music is truly
inspiring
[Music]
i think any instrument but especially
violin
the way i play automatically just sounds
different than the way someone else
plays
[Music]
it's really cool how you develop a voice
in a form of expression that's kind of
unique
it just clears my mind
and lifts my spirit there's not anything
else i found that does that
[Applause]
the decemberist tour brought me to
nashville where we played the historic
ryman theater
[Applause]
a day between shows gave me a chance to
explore the city known for its honky
tonks and live shows
[Music]
but i was here for something else to
track down an 80s icon
[Music]
the year is 1988 big hair and denim are
in
the ultimate lead singer and hair metal
kip winger and his band are at the top
of the charts
but the party that seemed like it would
never end suddenly came crashing down
no air play no singles
nothing
but it turns out this was just the
beginning for kip winger
i'm kip winger and i'm uh in the band
winger and i'm also a classical composer
at the height of my career we were
playing for thousands of people every
night and gold and platinum albums
[Music]
beavis and butthead was the biggest show
in mtv's history at the time and it
ushered in a whole new
genre of music
grunge and it completely ripped apart
the 80s hair bands and i was at the
scene of the crime my name was on the
little geeky guys t-shirt that
represented everything that sucked
lost the record deal lost the publishing
i was at my very lowest point i did say
well there's nothing else to do now
except that thing that i've always
wanted to do which is
really learn how to wield an orchestra
organically
[Music]
to go from a rock bass player to
composer is learning music all over
again
to do so later in life as kip did is
almost unheard of
[Music]
i could never even read an orchestral
score until i was 35
[Music]
10 15 years into it to finally start to
hear orchestras play my music and
realize oh my god this is really what
i'm here to be doing
[Music]
dude that's awesome
amazing
in this case i took a i'm calling it a
riff because that's my terminology from
being a rock guy
[Music]
[Music]
it was a scary and lonely path
i've got a record company that's going
why are you doing that you're a rocker
you need to rock and i'm like no no no i
don't need to rock i need to be doing
this
this kind of starts all on a rock rip
really
you know you kind of go against all odds
when you just believe in something
[Music]
despite the challenges with learning how
to compose kipp's persistence ultimately
led to a grammy nomination and
contemporary classical composition
it's a very cathartic healing experience
to
overcome my illiteracy in music at a
late age with not so much
self-confidence
it was like okay you know what i don't
suck like
it wasn't true what they all said
to be acknowledged with a composer
nomination from the grammys was
the greatest feeling of accomplishment
of my whole life
[Music]
my town of portland oregon isn't known
for having a thriving r b scene
but the portland i know has a secret
hidden in the heart of the city's music
culture is a master of soul who has
shared the stage with the likes of otis
redding and james brown
my sunny days
stay bright this established 78 year old
is proving that great r b can be found
anywhere
everything i do with you baby my name is
euro thomas
i'm singing with a band called the pain
we have a very uh unique style of rhythm
and blues
[Music]
i've been a r b musician for over 40
years
and i've lived in portland all my life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you know this one
they used to say portland didn't have
good musicians
they were saying portland
where is that who do you know in
portland
that's ever done anything i say i know
me
and i'm having fun
euros music has taken him as far as the
apollo theater in harlem
but after experiencing great achievement
the siren song of portland lured him
back home
hey chris how you doing
we met him at his place known for its
infamous sunday jam sessions with some
of portland's best musicians
portland to me is a very positive place
so i come back home where i know that
i'm positive
and i feel like uh maybe i can do
something in portland to help musicians
i
really have enjoyed sharing my soul
there are no words to explain that
feeling it's like magic
euro has played music through
segregation and the civil rights
movement watching portland transition
into the city it is today
the pacific northwest was very uh
segregated
there was a lot of places that you know
black singers and stuff couldn't go
so then we had opportunity to show the
people what music was really about it
wasn't about being
divided we didn't have
no black and white because we all did it
together
[Applause]
[Music]
i've played with
some very amazing people in my life
like mick jagger otis redding carla
thomas wonderful people
it was a blessing for me to have all the
experiences that i can say that i was a
part of
[Music]
euro's musical journey has taken him
around the country but i'm happy he's
made his way back home to portland
because every city needs an unexpected
treasure
i'm back home now with the most
wonderful group that i can ever
deal with
the guys
are call the pain
and we're gonna bring it
[Music]
i've traveled to virginia and stepped
back into history to meet a musician
who's perfected a rather unusual medium
glass
the glass harmonica really had this
effect on people who heard it
i mean they were saying it was the most
beautiful sound they'd ever heard
and there were a lot of beautiful sounds
in the 18th century
but you know there was something
different in the sound in the harmonica
i wanted to give people
that come to williamsburg and experience
that they wouldn't get anywhere else
my name is dean shasta here in
williamsburg virginia where i live and i
play the glass harmonica but i also play
a number of other glass instruments too
like this crystal bache
dean has spent years mastering the
skills necessary to play this family of
glass instruments
all of which originated with the glass
harmonica an instrument with a very
unexpected creator
[Music]
the glass monika was invented by
benjamin franklin in 1761.
he had seen somebody play on the wine
glasses and a concert and he got the
idea that you could actually use glass
in an entirely different way
you could actually make them rotate with
a flywheel you're working with your foot
and with wet fingers you can play it
very much like a keyboard
[Music]
i almost got it
obviously you don't tune this instrument
no that's the one nice thing everybody
has to tune to me
first thing you need to do is get your
hands really clean
and that takes a high calcium content in
the water which they happen to have here
at this theater so i've got these jugs
but i literally actually bring the water
from the theater back to my house to
have the same water to play with all the
time
skin absorbs moisture and so you really
want your hands to start wrinkling up a
little bit too
the condition of the skin on your
fingers is really what produces the
sounds
and those mesmerizing sounds produced by
skin on glass are not limited to the
glass harmonica or the crystal bachet
the technique has led to some truly
bizarre instruments
[Applause]
[Music]
i've heard the argument made that you
know we've gone as far as we can with
acoustic instruments
if you think about glass music as a
still unexplored musical frontier it's
pretty exciting to think what
instruments we could try in glass you
know but we don't know until we do we
make these instruments what they're
going to be like
i think we should know about the glass
of monica because it's truly the first
american instrument you know aside from
the native american instruments already
here
[Music]
i absolutely had to teach myself how to
play
my only sources were reading what
franklin wrote and these other guys back
in the time
it is new every day
every time i sit down and play the
harmonica it is a fresh experience and a
challenge each time
[Music]
my next stop takes me to new york city
trouble started with my eyes when i was
16 17. and by the time i was 18 i had to
stop driving doctor said you legally
blind you got 10 600 vision you can't
you can't be behind the wheel and be
safe
i have visual imperatives but legally
blind boy paxton is the stupidest stage
name i could come up with so i just
omitted the legacy
my name is geron paxton
born south central los angeles currently
of new york city in the world traveling
i'm a music physician
doctor feel good of music as it was
jaron is a master of forgotten music
the first time i heard him play i
thought i was listening to some old
obscure 45s
he can pick up almost any instrument
that sounds like he just stepped off the
mississippi delta
[Music]
i play
guitar banjo harmonica
piano
fiddle
and some other instruments that are
reserved for private pleasure
what
get your mind out of the gutter
people call this traditional music and a
lot of people tend to think of me as
revivalists i don't tend to think of
things in those terms because i'm a
musician this is music i always played
and always played it for my family
it's not old or traditional or throwback
i'm just a dude that plays music that my
folks and i want to listen to
play the melody with the
right side no way and you play the
harmony with the left side i've got
insane oral skills
[Laughter]
one of my favorite things about jaron is
that he's on a historical mission of
sorts
rediscovering for the rest of us the
original black music of america
people don't associate the banjo with
black people anymore
and you know 200 years ago that's all
you associated with
oh baby
that's my direction uh to find the music
that relates to my culture i had to go
back i had to go back past recording
history i had to go back to the 1840s to
hear what that kind of music sound like
and seeing as there ain't no records of
it i have to recreate it you know i'm
i'm one of a handful of black banjo
players left in the world
i figured to represent black banjo music
all i had to do was just act natural
back home in south central i play the
music like my grandma taught me from the
cotton field
it don't have too much european
overtones and influences the techniques
and a lot of the melodies are made out
of whole cloth by the builders of
america
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you so much
my gangster brother
and
after watching geron at the jalopy
theater in brooklyn play songs that are
100 years old it's easy to see why he
can captivate an audience
it takes me you know it's my music it's
my culture and it's my passion and i
don't watch tv and i don't have too many
other hobbies so this is what i get into
and i get into the history of it
[Music]
it seems to be more entertaining than
any book and any story you could read
because it's all real and there's more
of it to be discovered
[Applause]
hawaii offers so much beauty
from cliffs rising out of the ocean
to rolling hills and lush green valleys
but what surprised me when i got here
was the deep-rooted community of cowboys
something normally associated with the
southwest
a lot of people they don't realize
how far back we go being hawaiian
cowboys
as part of our heritage
we had
cowboys here on the big island before
there was any states west of the
mississippi including texas
the influence of spanish cowboys called
vaqueros is ever present in hawaiian
culture
they came here in the 1800s to teach the
islanders to herd cattle bringing with
them a lasting way of life culture
and a unique style of music called slack
key
[Music]
hey
how's it going what's up
here you just you heard us from i just
heard you from up
there welcome
slackkey style involves loosening the
string while tuning to create a sweet
soothing sound synonymous with the aloha
nature of hawaii
when the volcanoes came here they
brought the guitar in along with them
they brought some open spanish tunings
and they taught the hawaiians how to
play these tunings so you know
so hawaiians played it learned it and
then they created their own style of
playing kilowatt is called
islaki
[Music]
the cowboys
does everything from a to z
work the cattle burn the cattle
[Music]
and when the job's done
they play slack key
and sometimes they play music right
there where they're at
i've never seen a paniolo without his
guitar it's it's like a fish without
water
[Music]
the authenticity of libra and the
paniolo's blew me away
modern-day folk music is rooted in
historical themes like coal mining and
railroad work even though today's
musicians have never likely done these
jobs
but liebert embodies everything about
the lifestyle he's a true hawaiian
cowboy who also happens to be one of the
best slack key guitarists
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm very
appreciative
to the vaqueros who came here
to teach
us hawaiians
how to be
cowboys
and
we created our own
style
of being cowboys which is
a paniolo
every time i looked at you
i just don't it's something that is is
really
valuable in our way of life
if you don't
pass this knowledge
down to the next generation
it's going to be lost
this is a really really important part
of our heritage that we want to continue
someone's going to call me hawaiian i'm
not going to say no
hey you're ahoy all right good yes
you're upon your
[Music]
you